you know the traditional Vision which is
to be the best you know or to hit some
certain Financial goal like literally
the front line person doesn't care about
that at all that literally is about you
not me yeah but when you when you um
when you say I I and I will go back to
the arbitrary example I gave you know
let's say to make everybody feel safe
and cared for right that's what we care
about and so we're going to actually
give you training
beyond the technical skills we're going
to give you training and how and human
skills right because we give hard skill
training we very rarely give human
skills training by the way I hate the
term soft skills hard and soft are
opposite yeah good
um uh and so are we actually teaching
our Frontline folks how to how to um how
to have resolve conflict
I mean that happens you know some
somebody says I don't like this work
you've done how does that go do you have
any idea how that conversation is going
to go when you're not there right you
know are we teaching them listening
skills are we teaching them how to give
and receive feedback maybe they have
there's two or three of them on a job
and one of them is slightly more senior
like are we teaching them these skills
that make them better at their job with
each other and with the with the
customers and by the way those are
skills they're taking home you're making
them better human beings
um and by making them better human
beings it makes them super loyal to the
company so I might get it offered a
better job somewhere else and you know
there's of course there are minimum
standards of pay that they have to meet
but at the end but there are once you
reach those thresholds somebody can say
I I'd rather work here because of the
way that my boss makes me feel because
the way the company makes me feel and I
think that there's a huge opportunity in
this industry in these industries to
double down on what quite frankly is
good leadership
um uh and I think one of the reasons
that the these industries are considered
Commodities is because we treat those
workers as Commodities we treat them as
as replaceable hourly workers and so
they act like Commodities and they treat
uh the customers like Commodities and
we've created that commodity industry
it's not necessarily the product itself